[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de Paf
nous allons essayer son jouet de Madame
Irma de voir ce qui va se passer dans
les dans les mois qui viennent peut-être
à la rentrée 2020 avec la guerre du
crâne la crise énergétique l'inflation
et leurs conséquences sur les
collectivités locales et sur les
entreprises pour reparler Véronique
Jérôme bonjour vous êtes maître de
conférence en économie gestion à
l'Université de Paris Saclay et voilà
donc et aussi vous êtes la fondatrice
cofondatrice cofondatrice
je vais peut-être vous présenter d'abord
vous êtes invités d'accueillir dit
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le président
du Medef Yvelines voilà chef
d'entreprise vous-même bien sûr
c'est une condition silicone
Jean-Baptiste bonjour Patrice vous êtes
le maire de Villepreux vous êtes
responsable modem aussi des Yvelines et
Michel Laugier bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateurs des Yvelines vous êtes
l'ancien président de de 50 ans en
Yvelines donc voilà évidemment on va
parler avec vous des des problèmes des
des collectivités locales je voulais
juste vous raconter ou quoi élection
stop est un est un site de recherche qui
fait des prévisions politiques pas sur
les sondages mais si on se basant sur
les anciens les des façons de gens ont
voté sur le comportement et en janvier
dernier quand quand Zemmour était encore
donné au deuxième tour dans les sondages
réglections scope avait donné à la
virgule près le résultat du premier tour
des présidentielles dit ça comme ça donc
c'est un site assez formidable dans les
prévisions
peut-être avant de commencer de
commencer l'émission sur les questions
économiques Michel legier vous êtes
sénateur alors vous n'êtes pas
LRP mais vous êtes
vous êtes élu sur la liste de Gérard
Larcher
au Sénat Éric Ciotti a été élu hier
président de LR quel est votre réaction
vous direz vous l'avez dit Patrice je ne
suis pas élèves donc c'était une
élection interne alors cioti est sorti
il a pas il a fait un score
53,15 donc c'est pas mal mais
ça veut dire qu'il y a deux courants
très forts au sein des DLR et Bodo
retaillod que je connais bien que je
côtoie au quotidien a fait aussi une
très belle campagne moi ce qui m'importe
aujourd'hui c'est pas de savoir qui est
président qui qui est président DLR est
c'est ce surtout qui va rassembler qui
va rassembler parce que moi je ne crois
que aujourd'hui au rassemblement
d'ailleurs on a toujours gagné dans le
rassemblement dans les périodes
anciennes le RP et l'UDF était ensemble
quand on voulait gagner ça a été pareil
aussi dans des élections départementales
régionales voire locale donc moi je ne
crois qu'au rassemblement et aujourd'hui
c'est pas parce que la tête d'un parti
que on va réussir la seule réussite pour
moi ça sera la personne qui aura un vrai
projet et qui sera capable de rassembler
je vous rappelle aussi que il y avait
une autre élection dans un parti
centrices c'est Hervé Marcel donc le
président du groupe 1h centriste dans
lequel je siège au Sénat qui a été élu
président de l'UDI je connais Hervé lui
aussi il est pour le rassemblement donc
j'attends le rassemblement et donc
peut-être la personne qui pourrait
rassembler tout ça vous la voyez venir
si ça serait facile que d'autres aussi
le revu moi aujourd'hui peut-être que
vous voulez peut-être faire appel
il y a des personnalités aujourd'hui
maintenant encore faut-il que elles
mettent sur la table ce qu'elle souhaite
faire mais surtout dans un esprit de
rassemblement il y aura rien qui se fera
si chacun reste dans son parti si chacun
reste dans sa chapelle
sur cette élection de derricki alors
donc représentant du potable évidemment
oui oui c'est évidemment une élection
interne
Eric Ciotti vient confirmer pour moi une
une tendance qu'on sent venir depuis un
certain temps chez les républicains
c'est quand même un glissement de la
base militante vers voilà vers une
frange un peu plus un peu plus droitière
moi je vais être très curieux de voir si
des passerelles vont être proposées avec
certains autres partis qui sont plus
classés à l'extrême droite on a vu
quelques discours de personnes issues
des républicains qui ont décidé de
d'aller soit vers Zemmour soit vers
Marine Le Pen dernièrement donc voilà je
pense que le spectre politique le champ
politique n'a pas achevé sa
recomposition il y a des choses qui ont
bougé au centre avec l'arrivée
d'Emmanuel Macron ça a fait bouger les
lignes à gauche on l'a vu pendant
l'élection présidentielle notamment avec
nupes maintenant on va voir ce qui va se
passer à droite donc moi je pense que
aujourd'hui il y a alors aujourd'hui il
y a une action du gouvernement une
action du président de la République qui
a même de rassembler en tout cas sur un
espace central dans lequel les centrices
sont évidemment les bienvenus et j'en
fais partie avoir maintenant comment ça
va se dessiner sur les sur les prochains
mois et les prochaines années en tout
cas c'est assez intéressant à suivre
politiquement parlant de voir comment
elle est évolue et avec deux tendances
quand même là qui était représentée sur
ce second tour Bruno Retailleau Eric
Chiotti ou sur deux tendances
conservatrices voilà il y a pas de
modérer et il y a pas de son triste et à
chaque fois il recule dans les dans les
élections avec cette enfin je pense
surtout que l'enjeu pour les
républicains sera de trouver
effectivement un candidat par la suite
qui sera en position de porter leur
couleur à l'élection présidentielle on
entend beaucoup parler de Laurent
Wauquiez voilà
c'est pas ma famille politique je n'en
dirai pas davantage non plus
il y avait il y avait deux aussi
tendance avec Bruno Retailleau par
exemple sur la réforme de la retraite il
était plutôt partisan de pouvoir
discuter avec le avec le gouvernement
souhaité plutôt dans a prior comme ça
dans une logique d'opposition un peu
systématique est-ce que vous pensez que
ça va changer peut-être au fond
l'attitude des sénateurs LR que vous
côtoyez vis-à-vis des projets du
gouvernement ou est-ce que ils garderont
leur conviction et je pense qu'ils vont
que chacun va garder ses convictions
derrière il y avait deux façons de voir
les choses Ciotti
issus qui est même de notre assemblée et
Bruno Retailleau issu du Sénat donc on
voit bien qu'il y a deux façons de voir
les choses et de pouvoir appréhender
certains sont dans l'opposition
systématique alors que d'autres sont
dans la dans la construction sur les
retraites ça fait des années et moi je
fais partie des sénateurs qui à
l'occasion de l'examen du texte sur la
sécurité sociale le Bel FSS on a
toujours voté des amendements pour la
réforme de notre retraite donc je dis ça
fait déjà plusieurs années que on le
fait et donc si le gouvernement nous
présente un texte qui reprend les idées
qui sont les notes depuis plusieurs
années pourquoi pas pourquoi on serait
osé d'accord alors on va on reparlera
peut-être de la réforme des retraites
tout à l'heure parce qu'on verra dans la
situation politique qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire ou pas faire comme comme réforme
mais on va commencer avec la situation
économique avec justement des menaces
qui pèsent sur la rentrée
[Musique]
alors justement oui je disais tout à
l'heure il y a cette situation
internationale la guerre du crâne et les
dépenses énergétiques remontées dépenses
énergétiques la rareté aussi d'un
certain nombre de produits et puis et
puis l'inflation évidemment qui qui
ronge le pouvoir d'achat
comment comment on va parler d'abord un
peu de vision politique ou économique et
puis on parlera des entreprises parce
que évidemment ça affecte la vie des
entreprises mais comment on peut
concilier justement un peu l'inconsciem
c'est à dire que on voit que les
dépenses publiques montent et en même
temps il faut protéger il y a des
boucliers pour protéger les les Français
comment on peut concilier les deux
est-ce que c'est considérable d'abord
c'est pas qu'il veut répondre Véronique
peut-être d'un point de vue politique
économique justement forcé de constater
que on dispose d'instruments qu'on a des
objectifs mais le problème c'est qu'on
ne peut pas avouer un instrument
plusieurs objectifs et là la politique
économique ne peut pas servir un double
intérêt c'est à dire que si on utilise
l'argument de la relance dans une vision
très keynésienne c'est-à-dire on
soutient la demande en subventionne on
fait quoi qu'il en coûte on a une
générosité en estimant en espérant
pardon très fort que cette chaîne
orosité va soutenir le la consommation
et va permettre de d'alimenter et de
soutenir une demande et donc de donner à
terme un peu plus de croissance au pays
ça ce serait ce serait l'idéal le
problème c'est qu'il y a généralement en
cours de route des éléments qui
interfèrent ce n'est possible que si le
pays a des problèmes au sens
conjoncturel donc si on s'attaque à des
problèmes conjoncturels passagers on
peut très facilement résoudre de
problèmes si les structures sont
atteintes ce qui est le cas de notre
économie et bien ce genre de politique
ne peuvent pas réussir et alors je vais
très très j'ai généralisé parce que ça
peut être très méchant et considéré que
finalement
le quoiqu'il en coûte était
inefficace mais
il fait très froid dans le studio je je
n'ai rien mais il fait très froid et
donc ce que j'essayais de dire c'est que
les politiques pardon j'ai complètement
sénateur c'est très grave non non c'est
pas bien les politiques conjoncturelles
quoi qu'il en coûte c'est du
conjoncturel et ça doit être efficace
tout de suite sinon à terme et bien ça
fait ça fait du déficit ça fait du
déficit ou la date du déficit ou de la
dette et c'est contre-productif et donc
on a ici un vrai souci qui est aussi la
chance je dirais du gouvernement c'est
qu'il y a pas de calendrier électoral à
court terme il y a pas d'élection donc
on peut se dire qu'on a un peu le temps
mais mais mais ce que je voulais dire
par là c'est que il y a pas d'élection à
venir mais on sort presque d'une
élection et on devrait être dans la
période d'état de grâce la honeymoon
normalement mais il y en a plus il y en
a jamais vraiment eu c'est là le premier
pas de soutien politique on manque de
crédibilité on manque d'efficacité avec
les les politiques économiques et puis
bah il y a il y a ceux qui vont élire
les politiques c'est-à-dire les
électeurs qui sont là et qui sont en
attente la vraie la vraie réponse ce
serait de retrouver de la croissance et
de la croissance fait repartir
justement entre le bois qui nous coûte
Michel legire peut-être ce que l'on
oublie aussi parce que là on parle de la
guerre en Ukraine on parle de la crise
énergétique faut aussi se rappeler
combien de traverser aussi oui une crise
de crise sanitaire
donc voilà donc aujourd'hui on va dire
que les problèmes se sont accumulés
l'état de grâce n'existe pas mais des
terrasses n'existent pas parce que tout
simplement c'est vrai que la campagne
électorale n'a pas été qu'elle est même
d'une qualité exceptionnelle et que il y
a pas eu de engagement fort pris par nos
politiques donc ce que je dis
aujourd'hui c'est que on se retrouve
dans une situation
effectivement elle est très complexe
elle est très complexe il faudrait que
l'économie reparte le problème de
l'économie aujourd'hui j'ai une amie qui
a caricature en me disant je croyais
qu'avant trouver des j'ai découvert que
devenait du crâne voilà donc c'est la
moutarde maintenant
on en arrive quand même à avoir des des
éléments qui ne sont pas du tout
expliqués ce n'est pas du tout expliqué
et puis il faut quand même rappeler on
est là on a commencé un petit peu à voir
une toux avec Madame parce que c'est
vrai qu'il fait froid dans le studio je
ne me plains pas mais faut quand même se
rappeler comment arriver là
ça va venir
c'est que on oublie aussi on oublie
aussi que il y a eu des choix politiques
dramatiques notamment sur le ducléaire
aujourd'hui nous sommes dépendants au
niveau de la foi mais de choix anciens
donc je veux dire c'est vrai que aussi
vous savez quand on est élu local et je
me tourne vers mon collègue à côté vous
êtes responsable mais il n'y a pas de
filtre entre la population et vous là
aujourd'hui il faut quand même qu'on le
dise haut et fort c'est des choix
politiques qui ont été gravissimes par
Monsieur Hollande faut dire les noms
aussi mais aussi qui ont été validés par
Monsieur Macron qui était capable pas
loin de là exactement mais je veux dire
on oublie aussi c'est vrai que là aussi
il y a on est dans une politique de
communication on oublie parfois aussi un
peu l'étape d'opinion à un moment donné
oui
on oublie aussi de rappeler que Monsieur
Macron était ministre monsieur Hollande
mais on dirait qu'il est tout nouveau
qu'il arrive et qu'il avait rien fait
avant et que pendant aussi quelques
années c'était son conseiller à l'Élysée
donc voilà donc il y a des choix
dramatiques et dire que chacun n'assume
ses choix mais c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui la réalité c'est que nous
avons des concitoyens qui doivent faire
face à toutes ces difficultés en plus le
froid arrive plus tôt que prévu voilà
mais entre nous vous croyez que c'est en
faisant des discours ou un infantilise
les Français attention pas chaud à plus
de 19 et tout vu le coût de l'énergie
dans les collectivités ça fait des
années qui font des efforts dans la
gestion on va pas attendre que Madame
Borg nous explique comment on doit faire
je sais pas que on est quand même
confiance en nos concitoyens et je crois
que aujourd'hui c'est ce qui est un
petit peu cassé c'est la confiance qu'on
a entre les citoyens les dirigeants
politiques et on y reviendra notamment
aux gens qui dirigent les collectivités
locales qui ont montré pendant la crise
sanitaire vous en parler voilà qui
pouvait prendre les choses en main mieux
que l'État souvent et qui vont le faire
attends je parle de modéliser
parce que c'est pas je veux dire le plan
aujourd'hui que l'on a éventuellement
sur les délaissages écoutez-moi je suis
désolé c'est encore que de la queue de
la communication on se retrouve dans des
situations aujourd'hui où les élus
devraient encore faire face parce que
quand il y aura des problèmes quand il y
aura pas de joie dans une école on va
pas passer un coup de fil à la première
ministre on va aller directement voir le
maire et c'est à lui après de faire les
choix et de se débrouiller avec le peu
de moyens qui lui reste on y reviendra
on va parler des collectivités
d'abord peut-être de la situation aussi
des entreprises avec plusieurs problèmes
qui se posent d'abord un problème un peu
général qui est le problème du
recrutement de des emplois qui sont
proposés qui ne trouvent pas de preneur
c'est notamment dans ce département
enfin oui oui bah écoute
on peut se réjouir parce que dans le
département c'est vrai le l'emploi des
cadres et quasiment sont pratiquement
plein emploi il faut s'en réjouir mais
néanmoins il y a des problématiques de
recrutement qui sont je dirais assez
intense en fonction des secteurs
d'activité le Medef s'implique
énormément pour aider les entreprises à
trouver et à recruter nous travaillons
avec les services de l'État pour
mettre en place des mécanismes pour
favoriser notamment l'alternance
notamment la la le dispositif transition
pro voilà donc donc cette problématique
impacte les entreprises impact sur la
croissance des entreprises et le
développement des entreprises il faut
absolument qu'on puisse discuter avec ça
c'est plutôt presque une bonne nouvelle
parce que
malgré les difficultés
[Musique]
il y a encore le chômage n'est pas
remonté comme on aurait pu le prendre
après alors deuxième difficulté c'est le
difficulté d'approvisionnement d'un
certain nombre de matière ça et vous
avez des entreprises qui qui vous
contactent pour
l'inflation notamment des produits
énergétiques à impacter considérablement
l'approvisionnement matière première
aussi
certaines matières indispensables
notamment dans la construction
automobile qu'on importait de Russie ont
été
stoppés pour différentes raisons bien
évidemment ce qu'il faudrait aujourd'hui
c'est que nous nous discutons pas mal
avec notamment mettre en allemand pour
mettre en place des solutions communes
pour que les entreprises européennes
sécurisent
leur approvisionnement en matière
première et ça c'est des choses qui sont
aujourd'hui assez critiques et on voit
bien que le moindre frémissement le
moindre bouleversement en dehors de
l'Europe impact les entreprises
européennes impact économie européenne
parce que l'importation dépendra je
dirais d'une manière assez considérable
d'importer de la matière première de
l'international pose un souci donc notre
challenge entre entre guillemets c'est
de pouvoir sécuriser nos
approvisionnements en matière première
et vous avez des craintes sur ce qui
peut se passer dans les prochains mois
pour un certain nombre d'entreprises là
justement on disait jusqu'à présent ça
tient ça tient le coup mais est-ce que
on peut redouter des faillites des
fermetures
il y a eu des
prédictions de faillite assez massives
notamment le covid avec la crise etc etc
heureusement si on peut arriver donc ça
prouve que l'économie
en tout cas en France est solide tiens
elle est sur des bases assez assez
saines et assez assez importante puisque
de toute façon les entreprises ont
considérablement travaillé leur fonds
propres on considérablement travaillé
leur moyen de financement pour pouvoir
je dirais pérenniser l'activité
mais nous sommes inquiets quand même
parce que la crise énergétique elle est
très difficile
la crise énergétique mais je dirais dans
une situation critique l'exploitation
des entreprises et même aujourd'hui on
est en train d'assister à des situations
où des entreprises sont amenées à
renégocier leur leur contrat
d'approvisionnement en énergie et ils
sont ils subissent effectivement des
augmentations considérables mais le
souci le souci c'est que ces
problématiques de prix d'énergie n'est
pas pareil partout dans le monde
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il y a un
rapport de 1 à 10 avec des entreprises
ou avec une situation soit aux
États-Unis soit en Chine
et nos redoutons un problème pernicieux
qui pourrait mettre à mal la
compétitivité de nos entreprises à cause
de cette inflation considérable de
l'énergie oui
dans le sens du président
en sachant que nous sommes ici dans le
département des Yvelines qui est quand
même un département plutôt privilégié
par rapport à d'autres d'une part parce
que on a des entreprises importantes
parce que on est un territoire attractif
et sans oublier aussi la dynamique
politique qu'il y a je parle sous le
contrôle du vice-président de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin
Yvelines au Daily d'agglomération qui a
même qui communiquement qui
économiquement et qui même quelque chose
de très impressionnant un département
aussi qui est de beaucoup et une région
voilà
c'est vrai que c'est pas pareil dans
d'autres territoires français mais par
rapport ce que vous dites c'est vrai que
quand même une économie qui est capable
relativement solide en France et c'est
vrai que alors c'est vrai que il y
aurait peut-être un impact sur
l'empreinte carbone mais ça serait bien
que les Français voyagent un petit peu
pour savoir ce qui se passe à cœur ça
leur ferait du bien plutôt que d'avoir
toujours le côté râleur
j'étais il y a quelques semaines avec le
dirigeant de d'un grand groupe français
de la mode de luxe soyez parce que je
veux dire ça commence à relever ça fait
des parrainage et
voilà tout à fait et lui donc il est
responsable azi pour ce groupe là et il
me disait mais vu de l'Asie vous pouvez
pas savoir qu'est-ce que je suis fier
d'être français et disait regardez bien
dans toute activité économique quelle
qu'elle soit il y a un goût prof
français qui figure soit dans le top 3
au pire dans le top 5 et c'est vrai mais
il suffit qu'on regarde et j'ai fait
cette expérience là et que ce soit dans
le dans le bâtiment puisqu'on a des
grandes entreprises dont dû à installer
sur le territoire de 50 ans c'est vrai
que ce soit dans l'aviation c'est vrai
l'armement c'est vrai les produits de
luxe
ne parle pas donc c'est vrai que on a
quand même une puissance économique
importante et il faut il faut que on
l'accompagne il faut qu'on locale et il
faut aussi que on arrête de vouloir
toujours avoir comme cible l'entreprise
à l'entreprise parce que pour le moment
les seules emplois réels et qui
survivent si dans le site dans le privé
parce que ce sont de vrais emplois
contre moi ce qu'on peut créer dans le
public Jean-Baptiste enfin sur votre
territoire par exemple il y a les
entreprises il y a aussi des artisans il
y a aussi des commerçants qui qui
craignent comme les mots qui viennent
non mais je rejoins ce qui a été dit
alors je sais pas si l'économie
française est si solide que ça en tout
cas ce dont je suis assez persuadé c'est
qu'elle a été accompagné et soutenue au
moment où elle devait l'être et je
rejoins ce que disait madame Jérôme dans
le sens où les mesures fortes qui ont
été décidées par le gouvernement
notamment pendant la crise covid que
nous on a élu locaux contribué à mettre
en place ou en tout cas il fallait faire
beaucoup d'informations et de pédagogie
parce que on le sait comment ça se passe
une fois que les aides sont votées sont
lancés pour savoir si on est éligible il
y a toujours des histoires de critères
nous on le vit en tant que collectivité
avec bon c'est toujours après une autre
histoire mais en tout cas l'économie a
été soutenue et là où je rejoins madame
Jérôme c'est que la crainte qu'on peut
avoir aujourd'hui qu'on soit du côté des
entreprises du côté des particuliers
qu'on bénéficie aussi des boucliers
tarifaires de choses comme ça sur la
période de cette crise énergétique c'est
est-ce que le conjoncturel ne va pas
devenir du plus long terme jusqu'à
devenir du structurel quelque part
on dit que l'inflation pourrait baisser
2023 mais bon vous connaissez
l'attachement de notre famille de ma
famille politique la question de la
dette qui a été portée avec force en
exactement quand on est dans un pays
aujourd'hui qui a 2000 milliards de
dettes alors le quoi qu'il en coûte je
crois qu'il a été effectivement
essentiel et vital au moment de la crise
sanitaire il est quelque part encore un
peu aujourd'hui mais on sait que ça
pourra pas durer et c'est cette forme-là
cette fameuse formule du de du
porte-parole du gouvernement de l'époque
Gabriel attaque qui disait on passe du
quoi qu'il en coûte à combien ça et bon
ça veut pas dire que le gouvernement ne
regardait pas avant combien les
dispositifs d'aide ou d'accompagnement
pouvaient coûter mais on sait que sur le
long terme même sur le moyen terme un
tel niveau d'engagement de l'État
financièrement parlant pour les
particuliers les entreprises les
collectivités un petit peu mais un peu
moins quand même
ça va être compliqué ce sera pas tenable
et donc Madame le disait et Monsieur le
créateur aussi
contradiction entre en effet à quel
moment est-ce qu'on veut protéger et
création de richesse qui va nous
permettre aussi de dégager de la
croissance parce que je crois que la
croissance est encore le moteur
économique de ce pays notamment de
l'Union européenne et c'est vrai que les
prévisions varient quand même assez
régulièrement donc personne ici vous
avez commencé une mission en disant sans
jouer les Madame Irma c'est difficile
pour nous de nous projeter sur ces
questions mais peut-être un mot sur les
collectivités
il faut chauffer les piscines les écoles
de plus en plus cher depuis que vous
avez été obligé de faire des choix
depuis mon élection en 2020 en juillet
2020 j'ai accepté que j'allais avec mon
équipe municipale et avec nos habitants
que nous allions vivre un mandat de
crise c'est un mandat de gestion de
crise on fait de la gestion des affaires
courantes on essaye de porter autant que
faire ce peu les projets pour lesquels
en l'occurrence à Villepreux les villes
nous ont accordé leur confiance mais
c'est évidemment complexe aujourd'hui
c'est évidemment complexe parce que on
passe notre temps et on le fait et on le
fait aussi avec plaisir parce que on est
là pour aider les gens on est là
effectivement pour être vigilant à ce
que personne soit laissé du bas-côté de
la route mais la crise sanitaire on a
répondu présent et aujourd'hui monsieur
le sénateur disait la crise énergétique
on est encore en première ligne on est
en première ligne et nous n'avons pas
obtenu même si là il y a quelques
avancées qui ont été annoncées par la
première ministre très récemment
l'accompagnement qui nous permet de
répondre présent aujourd'hui je vous
prends juste un chiffre pour moi qui est
extrêmement révélateur de la situation
des collectivités je vais parler de
l'exemple que je connais le mieux celui
de la commune de Villepreux de 20 31 à
2023 je prends un million en plus de
dépenses de fonctionnement sur la seule
partie de l'énergie un million d'euros
électricité gaz
comment est-ce qu'on fait face à ça
comment est-ce qu'on fait face avec le
revers de la médaille d'être un très
beau département très attractif pour les
collectivités c'est-à-dire que on le
sait ce gouvernement et le premier
depuis un moment avoir stabilisé
l'enveloppe des dotations à l'échelle
nationale mais par des mécanismes
péréquation dans lesquels je rencontre
je rentrerai pas aujourd'hui parce que
c'est assez technique je sais plus sur
les 200 et quelques 260 et quelques
communes des Yvelines il y en a
peut-être une dizaine ou une quinzaine
pour qu'il est les dotations sont en
augmentation ou reste stables toutes les
dotations des autres communes de ce
département diminue parce que nous
sommes dans un département jugé riche
avec un potentiel fiscal de nos
habitants
en deux mots pour résumer la difficulté
pour un élu local pour un maire et son
équipe aujourd'hui c'est de trouver un
point d'équilibre entre toutes ces
dépenses de fonctionnement qui sont
aujourd'hui subis liés à l'inflation
liée aux crises que nous traversons
comment est-ce qu'on arrive quand même à
garder des services publics ouverts des
services publics de première nécessité
c'est-à-dire les écoles c'est-à-dire la
mairie pour accueillir les villes
provient pour administratif des services
publics comment est-ce qu'on arrive à
faire ça comment est-ce qu'on arrive à
maintenir et je sais que c'est de plus
en plus compliqué et c'est pour ça que
je geste aucunement la pierre au
collègue qui sont obligés d'augmenter la
fiscalité locale mais comment est-ce
qu'on arrive nous à tenir les objectifs
et les engagements de pas augmenter la
fiscalité sachant que l'État les
augmente pas par ailleurs et le dernier
aspect c'est comment est-ce qu'on arrive
à porter le projet de mandat pour lequel
les villes provient les habitants nous
ont accordé leur confiance donc c'est de
plus en plus compliqué moi j'ai un corps
l'énergie parce que je viens d'arriver
mais pour discuter avec certains
collègues qui sont élus depuis deux
trois mandats c'est complexe et quelque
chose que je ne mesurais pas à ce point
c'est que j'ai un certain nombre de
collègues aujourd'hui qui se posent même
la question de savoir s'il rempliront ou
pas en 2026 et on voit beaucoup de baies
qui
renonce finalement à leur mandat il y
avait un projet d'autonomisation
financière des des collectivités locales
[Musique]
sauf que
dans la réalité c'est pas du tout ce qui
se passe puisque aujourd'hui les
communes en tant qu' ancien berge peut
vous en parler ont perdu leur autonomie
d'une part parce que aujourd'hui
regardez il n'y a plus de taxes
d'habitation plus de taxe d'habitation
française alors elle est compensée par
l'État mais elle est compensée sur une
photographie de 2017 c'est-à-dire tous
les nouveaux habitants qui arrivent dans
une commune depuis 2017 ne contribue pas
au fonctionnement de la copine donc ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui le maire de
Villepreux vous disait que il veut pas
agir sur le levier de la pression
fiscale parce qu'il n'y aurait aucun
seul levier
c'est celui du foncier bâti donc c'est
uniquement sur les propriétaires donc
c'est anormal qui est deux catégories de
de personnes dans une ville certains qui
vont payer plus impôts et d'autres pas
du tout pourquoi la taxe foncière
augmente un peu partout c'est la seule
moyenne aujourd'hui qui vous reste oui
mais c'est le seul levier qui vous reste
alors après c'est le problème c'est la
crédibilité c'est le contrat que vous
avez avec vos habitants où vous
justifiez cette augmentation elle peut
elle peut contribuer un petit peu aussi
au finances de la ville mais franchement
ce n'est pas aujourd'hui avec le seul
levier de la fiscalité que vous allez
pouvoir faire face aux difficultés parce
que le maire de Villepreux vous le
disait tout à l'heure pendant les années
Hollande on a vu la DGF la dotation
globale de fonctionnement c'est la
dotation de l'État pour le
fonctionnement des communes tout
simplement qui a fondu comme neige au
soleil aujourd'hui il y a des il y a des
communes qui contribuent c'est à non
seulement le touche rien mais elle le
contribue à payer exactement à payer
pour les autres alors moi vous savez la
solidarité je sais ce que c'est j'ai
toujours eu une politique sociale très
très forte sur la ville et sur
l'agglomération autrement avec les
villes les villes exactement exactement
[Musique]
riche qui donne du coup une pauvre ça me
dérange absolument pas au contraire
c'est la solidarité mais il faut pas
confondre commis de bien gérer et
commune mal géré c'est ça surtout or là
aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu la prime
je ne parlais que de fiscalité mais ce
qu'il faut savoir aujourd'hui c'est que
les coûts des produits ayant augmenté
les moins de travaux qui sont réalisés
dans une ville mais je veux dire près de
30 à 40%, c'est-à-dire comparaison les
travaux qui devaient avoir lieu en 2020
avec la crise covid ils ont été
repoussés sauf qu'aujourd'hui il vous
coûte 30 à 40% de plus je parle pas
parce que là c'est devenu aussi le même
phénomène dans toutes les villes des
Yvelines je suis sénateur donc je suis
au contact des mères tous les jours et
j'en vois beaucoup et je peux vous dire
que ils sont dans des difficultés
immenses la restauration scolaire
aujourd'hui c'est pareil mais ça prend
des proportions énormes
20% dans d'autres villes ils en sont à
30 ou 40% vivre c'est vraiment énorme
aujourd'hui et tout ça vous allez pas
pouvoir le faire uniquement porter par
les habitants ce sera sur le budget
communal mais au détriment de autre
chose donc il y aura des choix
importants à faire dans les dans les
semaines à venir déjà
c'est ce qu'on vous a expliqué
équilibrer le budget à venir 2023 et et
aussi pour finir l'année de 2022
sont dramatiques juste d'un mot très
court là-dessus Patrice je signais là
vendredi soir mon édito pour le prochain
magazine c'est très difficile parce que
on se retrouve dans la situation faut
dire la vérité de la situation telle
qu'elle est mais quelque part faut qu'on
arrive quand même à trouver quelques
motifs d'espoir et sans être Madame Irma
les motif d'espoir en ce moment ils sont
un peu plus compliqué à trouver mais
c'est le sénateur disait quelque chose
de très important parce que vous citiez
quelques communes comme trap comme
Guyancourt pour évoquer aussi la
nécessité d'avoir une politique une
politique une politique sociale et de
solidarité moi je fais presque plus la
distinction je la fais plus la
distinction aujourd'hui entre comme une
riche et comme une pauvre parce qu'avec
ce qu'on a traversé crise sanitaire
crise énergétique j'ai une demande moi
je la vois la demande sociale qui
explose du côté du CCAS du Centre
Communal d'Action Sociale de Villepreux
avec des nouvelles fragilités
financières sociales qui s'exprime qu'on
ne connaissait pas sur notre commune
donc ça veut dire qu'il va y avoir aussi
un besoin plus poussé d'accompagnement
aussi de ces personnes là donc ça va se
traduire forcément aussi par de la
dépense publique et de la dépense de
fonctionnement et là où je rejoins aussi
monsieur le sénateur logé c'est que
c'est très difficile d'être considéré
comme étant parfois mauvais élève alors
qu'on a été bon gestionnaire et je rends
aussi là hommage à mes prédécesseurs
quel qu'il soit parce qu'aujourd'hui
quand vous avez des Finances qui sont
bien gérés que vous avez un taux
d'endettement qui est tout à fait
correct vous êtes amené à davantage
contribuer justement pour les autres
donc c'est un petit peu la double peine
parfois et avec cette demande sociale
qui explose et ses nouvelles évolution
des coûts de l'énergie on a besoin nous
d'avoir certaines marches de manœuvres
juste pour faire le lien avec le monde
économique
vous savez je reprends mes anciens
habits de journalistes donc comme ça ça
va vous la perche
on a parlé des taxes mais il y a aussi
quelque chose de très important c'est la
suppression éventuelle parce que pour le
moment au sein de l'avant réintroduit de
la CBA c'est-à-dire c'est ce qui reste
de la contribution des entreprises et le
lien avec le territoire local le lien
avec les toit local si supprime encore
ce lien alors déjà qu'on a supprimé avec
les habitants si on suit le lien avec
les chefs d'entreprise je peux vous dire
que je ne vois pas demain comment les
choses vont se passer il faut qu'il y
ait un cercle vertueux un cercle
vertueux les entreprises viennent mais
les collectivités s'ils font l'effort
dans les transports dans l'aménagement
du territoire dans la proposition de
commerce de service voilà et ce lien là
aujourd'hui il existe justement grâce à
cette contribution si demain ça n'existe
plus je peux vous dire que ça va être
dramatique et la puissance économique
qu'avait l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin risque de s'étioler dans
les années à venir justement acquérir
dans les entreprises qui risquent de
rencontrer le plus grandes difficultés
c'est plutôt les petites et moyennes
entreprises
oui parce qu'il y a une fragilité
la fragilité dans ce segment
la multiplication effectivement
je dirais que 95% des entreprises sont
de petites entreprises en France
les financements les fonds propres etc
etc ce sont ces entreprises là qui ont
une fragilité financière et qui peuvent
éventuellement présenter un risque je
dirais de faillite interne mais je
reviens à ce que disait nos élus
c'est vrai l'équation se complique se
complexifie ce que nous représentons des
entreprises on comprend bien la demande
d'autonomie je dirais fiscale des
communes et des collectivités ce qu'on
souhaite pas c'est que ça se traduise
à la compétitivité des entreprises ça
c'est le premier point les fameux impôts
de production qui vont être supprimés
c'est vrai on a appelé cette nouvelle
parce que ce sont des impôts qui sont
injuste qui sont pas compréhensibles ça
veut dire avant de produire le premier
produit on est déjà amené à payer des
impôts donc c'est très compliqué à gérer
ce que je souhaiterais dire c'est que
enfin on appelle le son à donner bien
sûr nos élus
ils ont leurs compétences ils gèrent
leur collectivités comme ils peuvent
mais je dirais
mais nous comme on gère nos entreprises
on essaie de diminuer les tout ce qui
est coup de fonctionnement et surtout
développer l'investissement il est vrai
qu'en France on souffre de quelque chose
c'est le fameux millefeuille
administratif c'est-à-dire parfois on a
du mal à comprendre quelle est la
différence entre services de la
préfecture de la région de l'interco de
la commune département
c'est assez compliqué on a tous parlé à
un certain moment élu
acteur économique etc de la fameuse
simplification malle vient pas
c'est toujours aussi compliqué c'est
toujours moins compliqué parce qu'il y a
des choses qui ne voulaient mais ce
qu'il faudrait c'est simplifier en tout
cas nous Mède on a un credo c'est une
taxe une compétence une collectivité
d'accord et vous savez comment on
appelle la simplification en France la
décomplexification
on a fait une maison de service public
on est rentré dans le dans et on va être
bientôt prochainement je l'espère
labelliser pour rentrer dans le
dispositif gouvernemental qui est une
bonne chose l'idée c'est de remettre des
services publics dans les territoires
ils avaient commencé plutôt sur les
quartiers prioritaires de la ville et
sur les communes un peu plus rurales
maintenant ça s'étend parce que encore
une fois on voit que il y a des besoins
dans l'ensemble des bassins de de
population
on fait exactement la même chose sur
réduction des dépenses de fonctionnement
mais c'est ce que je disais c'est que
optimiser aujourd'hui nous on est dans
une culture de l'optimisation et mes
prédécenseur mais des prédécesseurs
avant moi depuis des décennies donc les
marges de manœuvre elles sont elles sont
très réduites le problème c'est que
l'investissement en est impacté
aujourd'hui l'investissement est impacté
puisque quand vous avez des dépenses
subies qui évoluent avec une telle
hausse ça vient réduire votre votre
épargne et donc pour investir derrière
c'est éminemment complexe en tout cas
je vous rejoins sur les impôts de
production je pense que il y a besoin
d'un peu de respiration de votre côté et
donc si des choses peuvent être faites
je pense qu'il faut que il faut qu'elle
le soit là où je rejoins Sims sénateur
c'est ça va avoir des effets cette
suppression de la CVAE même si voilà au
gré des discussions il semblerait qu'il
y ait des choses qui avancent le point
d'interrrissage est pas encore trouvé
mais ça aura des répercussions surtout
sur un territoire territoire comme une
autre à 50 ans en Yvelines et moi je
suis un petit peu inquiet quand même de
cette réforme je dois l'avouer d'accord
je voulais vous dire que les problèmes
liés à la décentralisation essayer de
reconstruire quelque chose avec les
communes le Sénat qui est la maison des
groupes de travail qui se trouve en
place 5 octobre à l'initiative de Gérard
Larcher et donc on devrait un nouveau
pas nécessaire quand même hein
c'est que on peut faire un travail avec
l'ensemble des groupes politiques voilà
donc on a cette vision là on se comprend
se respecte on ne s'active pas depuis
les bancs et bosser beaucoup plus calme
parce que tout simplement la plupart des
sénateurs ont une expérience locale ont
été représentants
mais nous avons été en fonction voilà
donc quand on discute
on sait de quoi on parle voilà quand je
vais à Villepreux le maire n'a pas
besoin de me faire de gros discours on
va directement on parle de même langage
exactement voilà c'est beaucoup plus
facile et donc normalement on devrait
pouvoir communiquer certaines mesures
déjà envisagées dès le printemps
d'accord
chez cherche une voie médiane entre deux
centralismes fédéralisme mais ce qu'on
dit les spécialistes économies publiques
depuis déjà certains temps est-ce qu'il
y a d'être me semble-t-il considéré par
le Sénat c'est que la décentralisation
et une règle d'or la décentralisation ne
peut pas se faire sans une autonomie
fisc pas financière mais fiscale et à
partir du moment où vous avez la
maîtrise de l'assiette du taux et vous
pouvez voilà gérer les choses de façon
fiscalité
et en France on s'aperçoit quand même
qu'on a peut-être des tendances qu'on a
réussi
l'ambition de la décentralisation de la
réussira que si l'on parvient à mieux
décentraliser le pays c'est-à-dire avoir
un poids de la dépense locale sur la
dépense totale qui soit plus importante
on a 17 % faudrait le double
pratiquement donc faudra avoir un poids
plus conséquent de la dépense et du
budget en quelque sorte et ça passe
aussi par cet aspect et sur le plan des
sur le plan des impôts on sait aussi
qu'il y a un risque et c'est pour ça que
que ce soit pour les entreprises ou pour
les pour les le priver au public c'est
toujours la même chose les entreprises
c'est les prix les le public c'est des
impôts le risque c'est de vote avec les
pieds c'est à dire que quand vous jouez
quand vous pouvez jouer sur les taux
vous avez des bases riches ou moins
riches vous pouvez jouer sur les taux
pour essayer d'avoir de garantir un
certain des ressources fiscales et quand
vous jouez sur les taux il y a une
concurrence fiscale qui s'établit entre
les entre les col qui fait que on peut
essayer d'attirer d'attirer en baissant
un peu les taux donc cet aspect là il
faut bien il faut bien gérer il faut
bien il faut bien viser parce que
baisser un peu du tout vous risquez
d'avoir moins de recettes si ça ne prend
pas donc là c'est cet aspect de de vote
avec les pieds du fait que la population
peut échapper qui peut-être aussi peut
poser problème et puis simplement d'un
mot sur les sur les entreprises ce que
vous dites est tout à fait cohérent avec
ce que l'on entend quand on voit les
enquêtes qui sont menées la première
préoccupation c'est le manque de main
d'oeuvre parce que effectivement le taux
de chômage des cadres est à 4% mais le
taux de chômage des ouvriers il est 3
fois plus important donc là on a il y a
un vrai problème de recrutement en
France il y a de vrais inquiétudes
l'évolution est il est vrai qu'on est
qu'au début d'un phénomène les craintes
sont les marges pour les pour les
secteurs et l'industrie le bâtiment
semble beaucoup plus inquiet et c'est
normal et quand on est une autre enfin
quand on a un pays qui est
désindustrialisé ça signifie que
ce ces craintes on les entend moins
parce qu'il y a les services pour
secteur des services il semblerait
qu'ils s'en sortent mieux à ils s'en
sortent mieux et puis il reste aussi les
consommateurs les consommateurs qui sont
aussi des ouvriers et des salariés les
entreprises vont être obligées
d'augmenter les salaires 80% à peu près
des entreprises dans les enquêtes et ses
codes sur les PME et les TPE
80%, 78% précisément disent qu'elles ont
ou qu'elles vont augmenter les salaires
les parallèlement
simultanément je dirais il y en a 58%
qui disent qu'elles vont aussi augmenter
les prix et là le problème c'est qu'on
va enclencher la pré-salaire et on quand
on va s'arrêter le phénomène le vrai
problème
on alimente la pression
je dirais la spirale
non seulement
elle se propage au salaire et c'est une
course enfin parce que finalement le
salarié lui expliquerait que s'il
acceptait un peu de un peu de de enfin
de modération salariale
peut-être que il verrait son pouvoir
d'achat peut-être pas augmenter mais en
tout cas conserver pas forcément
l'augmentation des salaires ne
correspond pas forcément à une
augmentation
vous avez parlé du taux de chômage
notamment des des ouvriers je pense que
c'est là où ça doit nous interroger sur
la nécessité de rien industrialiser le
pays aussi et donc là on a on a enfin
avec tout ce qui est énergie
renouvelable et économie verte il y a
des choses à faire juste un mot vous
avez parlé de décentralisation on a eu
très récemment la séquence du du Congrès
des mères avec l'association des
merdique de France et toutes les
associations partenaires moi même je
suis plutôt dans celle des petites
villes de France
on demande pas un nouveau grand
chamboule-tout de la décentralisation
nous les élus c'est parce qu'on doit
faire on demande quelque chose de très
simple et vous l'avez évoqué c'est à
chaque transfert de compétences à chaque
compétence au bon échelons de
collectivité et avec les moyens qui
permettent de mener qui vont venir
madame Jérôme Le le la priorité
aujourd'hui n'est pas un nouvel acte
décentralisation mais c'est de bâtir
fiscale des collectivités ça c'est clair
peut-être on va peut-être voir quelques
données comme ça ils sont aussi un peu
rapidement parce que on a déjà pris
beaucoup de temps mais
quelqu'un ce qu'il faut savoir un peu
pour comprendre un peu les problèmes
auxquels nous sommes confrontés on va le
faire avec vous Véronique avec quelques
schémas
[Musique]
d'abord il y a peut-être le poids de
l'étage c'est pour ce qu'on le voit
après dans les dépenses publiques
mais bon il y a beaucoup de chiffres en
fait ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut voir
c'est qu'on
a pris on a pris le
plan le plus large que l'on pouvait ce
qu'on essaie de dire c'est que c'est une
inexorable croissance de la dépense
publique en France et pourquoi parce
qu'on a on a une logique qui pardon
alors je vais peut-être parler anglais
mais pardon de SPEN d'être taxes on
dépense et on prélève après on est dans
une logique on dépense avant de se
soucier de savoir si on aura les moyens
et puis après au pied du mur et bien
soit augmenter les impôts soit on
augmente la dette et la dette c'est les
impôts de demain donc c'est un choix
intergénérationnel à chaque fois donc là
on voit il y a pas vraiment de de choses
à dire alors effectivement
on voit bien c'est pas lié le plancher
qui devient le le plancher d'aujourd'hui
va devenir
enfin on a planché un plafond il le
plafond d'aujourd'hui va devenir le
plancher de demain donc on a ses effets
de seuil le plafond d'aujourd'hui
devient le plancher de ma et d'effet de
cliquer c'est de considérer que d'une
certaine façon on va s'habituer à la
dépense c'est à dire que ça devient ça
s'intègre les comportements
parce que moi j'ai pas entendu un seul
président de la République ne pas dire
on va
on va on va on va dépenser moins écoutez
même si certains l'ont dit ils ne l'ont
jamais fait
nous venons de voter au Sénat le budget
le péril 2023 mais qu'est-ce que je vois
c'est que un encore 150 milliards pour
équilibrer notre budget donc on va
encore emprunter parce que bon après il
faut rembourser le capital les intérêts
on va on va encore emprunter 270
milliards et qu'aujourd'hui on est à
3000 milliards de dettes avec voilà oui
et en plus
comme vous dites donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut vraiment avoir en tête
certaines choses on parlait tout à
l'heure de des salaires revus à la
hausse dans les entreprises
ça a été imposé aussi dans le dans le
public il y a eu la raison du bien de la
France je ne suis pas contre mieux payé
mieux payé les agents simplement
non simplement ça a été annoncé en cours
d'année sur un budget qui était déjà à
voter voilà donc il va falloir retrouver
son transfert pour exactement voilà donc
voyez bien que on est là je veux dire
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui et vous l'avez
dit l'argent public c'est ce qu'il y a
vous savez j'ai toujours une formule
c'est il n'y a pas d'argent public si on
peut jouer
et donc finalement à la fin c'est
toujours les contributeurs le
contribuable alors ceux où il y a bien
sûr des impôts qui sont prélevés sur
leur salaire et d'autres il y a pas
d'impôts voilà mais en tous les cas ce
sont toujours les mêmes qui vont qui
vont payer parce que ceux qui payent en
principe des impôts sur le revenu ce
sont les mêmes qui vont avoir subir des
augmentations de taxes de habitation au
niveau local
50% des des Français qui payent l'impôt
sur le web
un peu moi-même voilà donc au début 409
social au regard de du PIB alors là
100 millions d'euros sans masse
simplement pour montrer que finalement
les dépenses sociales il y a une cassure
elle dépasse en poids on est à 683
milliards en 2021 s'ils sont 11 presque
612 milliards pour l'État central donc
là on voit bien qu'il y a une cassure
les dépenses sociales
l'intérêt de ce graphique c'était ça
c'est de voir cette cassure ou le social
dépasse
sur sociale et pression fiscales c'est
le troisième graphique je vais vite hein
on voit bien aussi que finalement le les
administrations de sécurité sociale sont
principalement responsables de l'effet
de seuil et puis on voit aussi qu'il y a
alors c'était c'est quelque chose qui
qui est acté c'est on n'a pas de
croissance donc bien faut bien trouver
il faut bien trouver des ressources
l'effet de seuil est ici manque de
croissance donc on essaie de trouver des
ressources et on essaie de faire des
transferts de cot on va chercher des
ressources sur la peau donc on a une
voilà
ce qu'on peut démontrer encore plus
facilement sur le sur le le graphique
suivant je crois oui qui met bien la
différence entre la pression sociale et
la pression sociale et qui augmente
voilà et là ce sont ces aspect fiscal
des ressources viennent de plus en plus
par l'impôt c'est c'est bondelles
l'ancien de FO qui disait qu'on avait
tatisé la sécurité sociale mais il y a
un peu de ça derrière quoi voilà donc ça
c'est avec cette rupture et alors on a
alors une conséquence schéma avec une
conséquence politique c'est justement
cette intéressant des réformes et les
mesures sociales notamment sur la
retraite dans les différents mandats
présidentielles et on voit que c'est
Chirac
si on prend Chirac Sarkozy 11 réforme en
17 ans si on prend la gauche Mitterrand
en 14 ans il y a eu comme ça
le RMI la CSG de Michel rocards si on
prend ce qui a précédé si on met de
Gaulle pompidouche iSCAR tous ensemble
sur 16 ans il y a quand même eu 8
réformes avec quand même au départ les
caisses établies par le ministre
Jeanneret Jeannet pardon et Simone Veil
en 74 et puis quand on regarde plus près
de nous et bien il nous reste la période
alors François Hollande de réformes
voilà Touraine en 2014 voilà sur
l'allongement de la cotisation et puis
alors son si on regarde sur Emmanuel
Macron on a deux enfin peut-être mettre
un Astérix parce qu'il y en a une qui a
avorté en 2019 c'était lancé des
retraites et puis là donc il y a déjà il
y a une celle qui va vous dire peut-être
je voudrais qu'on va verser chez Max sur
le degré d'acceptabilité des réformes ça
c'est intéressant aussi
regardez les compilations des sondages
ce sont des sondages et on voit que les
choses se resserrent mais quand même il
y a encore un souci c'est le pour donc
c'est les favorable ce sont les réponses
et sont des qui ont répondu qu'ils
étaient favorables ou une réforme
réforme des retraites 60% sont
favorables et opposés
40%. et là c'est toujours le cas non là
c'est juste alors je suis désolé les
chiffres sont 2018 oui parce que
aujourd'hui je suis pas sûr qu'une
majorité des Français aujourd'hui si on
dit récent des retraites à 65 ans il y a
plus qu'à retraités qui sont d'accord
avec la réforme à 65 ans et c'est
toujours le problème c'est de c'est de
démontrer le la logique et le pourquoi
de la réforme en fait et ceux qui seront
pour seront forcément ce qu'on appelle
des frères riders c'est à dire ceux qui
vont en bénéficier sans en subir le coup
forcément si vous dit vous allez payer
plus d'impôts pour la fin vous êtes mais
si on vous dit que s'améliore votre
situation vous êtes forcément pour si
d'autres la finance c'est un peu ça
l'idée en fait
c'est à dire que
voilà
une recette à condition que s'il y a des
effets ce soit pour le voisin et pas du
tout pour soi donc la seule chose
aujourd'hui c'est que on l'a bien vu on
a pris du retard sous le mandat
précédent alors que devrait déjà dû le
faire je vous rappelle quand même là on
était encore dans une communication
intense on a quand même nommé au
commissaire qui a consulté une fois
qu'il a oui et une fois qu'il a rendu
son rapport on a dit même temps on va
consulter donc je veux dire si on a fait
que de la consultation et après on est
arrivé dans la crise sanitaire et tout
et bon les sites une réforme qui a
avorté
c'est bien ce que je dis que d'après du
temps on a pris beaucoup de retard tout
au long de ce schéma de celui qui était
qui était prévu la seule chose
aujourd'hui c'est que il faut il faut
bien que nier dans cette réforme parce
que il voit pas bien il va on finance
ces retraites
est-ce qu'on peut réformer pendant la
tempête dernière partie
[Musique]
des raisons
contre le mouvement contre
une petite précision par rapport à vos
chiffres et quand vous parlez du budget
social d'avu les schémas et tout c'est
du budget de l'État
centrale parce que ce qu'il y a aussi
les départements il y a aussi bien sûr
et les communes vous le disait le CCAS
aujourd'hui fait face à des demandes de
plus en plus importantes et la crise
énergétique vont vendre encore avoir un
effet important donc c'est ça aussi la
réponse sociale il faut des aussi parce
que vous parlez d'un seul de la
décentralisation il fallait beaucoup de
choses mais quand on doit analyser les
chiffres je crois qu'il faut les
analyser dans leur globalité et
peut-être c'est comme ça que de
véritables vision de l'état de santé
d'autres pays
alors vous disiez ce qu'on va conclure
là dessus puisque
on peut réformer pendant la tempête on a
vu en effet d'une situation économique
internationale difficile
alors il y a deux solutions parfois on
dit bon là on arrête tout c'est ce qui
s'est passé pendant par exemple pendant
la crise sanitaire ou bah non faudrait
former et notamment il y a cette réforme
des retraites dont on voit que bon elle
risque de provoquer des gros mouvements
sociaux vous vous dites il faut y aller
cette question moi je dis oui moi je dis
oui parce que je veux dire
on recule pour mieux sauter donc je veux
dire plus dur sera ensuite
ce seront les choix quand on va faire
plus tard c'est-à-dire que là aussi il y
a des déficits qui risquent d'arriver
qui risque de s'accumuler vous savez
c'est un petit peu comme la Cour des
comptes qui fait une audit sur les
finances des collectivités et en 2021
non les politiques sont riches mais non
2021 il y a pas eu de dépenses puisque
on était en crise
sanitaire dans dire que on parle de
vraiment des bons chiffres là je veux
dire effectivement on peut avoir une une
période qui soit plus favorable en ce
moment mais dès qu'on se projette sur
les avenir c'est impossible donc d'une
part 12 milliards de divisés en 2027 il
faut y aller il faut y aller parce que
sinon on n'arrivera pas à financer 2 il
faut y aller aussi parce que on a aussi
à assurer les retraites de ceux qui déjà
la retraite et avec aussi une
indexation parce que sinon de son sort
pas c'est en plus les personnes se
retraite aujourd'hui c'est sont celles
qui a travaillé le plus longtemps il
faut quand même s'en rappeler peut-être
pas dans la durée de cotisation mais au
moins on n'était pas au 35 heures quand
ces personnes étaient actives donc il
faut aussi qu'il y a juste retour des
des choses donc pour moi c'est
indispensable pour financer la retraite
de nos enfants et petits enfants et puis
surtout après pour permettre à ceux qui
sont de la retraite ou qui ne seront
prochainement à pouvoir continuer à
percevoir leur droit à la retraite sinon
on risque d'avoir de gros problèmes ça a
été le cas dans d'autres pays dans
d'autres pays je veux dire dès qu'il y a
une crise et qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on a
réduit le montant du versement des
retraites ça a été le cas d'Espagne en
Angleterre voir en Italie voilà donc
givre il faut quand même il agresse
aussi mais il faut que on soit
aujourd'hui réaliste et il faut pas
qu'on pense à nous et uniquement je dois
travailler oui je dois travailler un
petit peu plus favorable un âge
peut-être 64 65 ans ou à une
augmentation du nombre de danités
de base parce que si on commence à
partir vous savez sur la pénibilité on
ne s'en sortira jamais on part sur une
base et après on pourrait on examine le
cas par cas voilà donc ça a été le cas
pour des régimes spéciaux on a tout le
monde a été a été remis au même niveau
maintenant voilà ben je crois qu'il faut
qu'on parte dans le même logique il y a
un âge pour partir il y a duré de
cotisations et après on voit les
problèmes spécifiques mais on peut pas
tout faire en même temps il faut qu'on
s'aligne sur une base commune à tout le
monde et après on va revoir en plus
entre nous à part quelques cas
particuliers on entre dans la vie de
plus en plus tard
et aujourd'hui
quelque part il y a la logique qui se
trouve et je crois que vous savez quand
on fait de la de la politique il faut
avoir du bon sens et c'est avec ça qu'on
voit gagner sa carrière dit le Medef est
favorable
et favorable effectivement une réforme
de retraite parce que quand on regarde
quand on fait un benchmark
en France on part plutôt que nulle part
ailleurs ça c'est le premier point la
moitié des actifs liquide leur retraite
rapidement en bénéficiant soit d'un
régime spécial soit d'une retraite
anticipée
bien évidemment il faut regarder la
pénibilité mais là-dessus il y a deux
visions qui s'affrontent
la vision des organisations des
organisations syndicales c'est la
multiplication des régimes spéciaux
catégoriels sans regarder l'évolution
de l'environnement professionnel de ces
catégories et les adapter au fur et à
mesure par exemple pour les conducteurs
des phalishminots le conducteur de train
on va bien qui sont passés d'un métier
qui était pénible lorsqu'il y avait les
locomotives à vapeur aujourd'hui tout
est numérisé
etc donc ce sont des métiers qui sont
devenus très confortables donc c'est
incompréhensible qui continue à partir à
la retraite plutôt en tout cas nous mais
ce qu'on propose c'est
une visite professionnelle visite
médicale aux alentours de 50 ans qui
pourrait je dirais analyser l'aptitude
du du salarié du collaborateur voilà en
fonction de sa situation il y aura trois
options la première c'est il est apte à
continuer son activité donc le salarié
l'actif continue son activité s'il le
souhaite la deuxième option c'est
aménagement une usure professionnelle et
donc le faire bénéficier d'une formation
pour changer
d'activité ou secteur d'activité et puis
le troisième la troisième option c'est
l'usure elle est constatée médicalement
parlant et là effectivement le
l'actif peut partir à la retraite plutôt
voilà donc c'est c'est la proposition du
manège voilà et ben écoutez
malheureusement on a plus de
temps merci à tous on aura l'occasion de
reparler des réformes des retraites
notamment et une fois nous sommes
d'accord avec les élus il faut la faire
je pense que en période de crise comme
ça vous disait ce qu'il faut faire des
réformes il faut choisir les bons
combats et celui-ci il est vital il faut
pas oublier que cette réforme apportera
aussi des droits nouveaux parce qu'il y
a un impératif évidemment budgétaire
pour pour le pays pour trouver un
équilibre mais il y aura aussi des
droits nouveaux qui seront apportés
Zakaria Hardy Véronique Jérôme merci
infiniment et à très vite pour un
nouveau numéro de PAF
[Musique]